que se passe-t-il à Tours métropole
après l'affaire de la gifle donc celle
de l'insulte raciste proférée devant
témoins par son président à l'encontre
du maire de Fondettes les mots sale
portugais en marge d'un conseil
métropolitain continue ce soir de faire
réagir la classe politique tout en gel
mais d'abord ce propos peut-il tomber
sous le coup de la loi que révèle-t-il
des fractures au sein de la droite
locale éclairage avec Aurélie Renaud
c'est à la suite d'un conseil
métropolitain que Frédéric cogis aurait
dérapé envers Cédric des Oliveira ce
dernier réplique par courrier il indique
je cite que ce type de proporatiste est
profondément offensant d'autant plus
lorsqu'ils sont prononcés entre élus de
la République alors une nouvelle crise
politique est-elle en marche à Tours
métropole la droite est-elle aujourd'hui
formellement divisée et entre Cédric de
Oliveira et Frédéric oziste le reproche
de départ c'est que ces rides d'Oliveira
n'a pas souvenu une proposition de
former un groupe de la majorité par
Frédéric Augis et là on est vraiment sur
deux courants et il y a les sénatoriales
qui arrivent cette année donc derrière
ça on voit il y a le département
j'engère un pommier qui a publié un
communiqué ce matin donc évidemment les
portes sont ouvertes il y en a qui vont
s'enfoncer dedans les propos ont-ils été
tenus dans la sphère publique ou privée
si aujourd'hui aucune plainte n'est
arrivé sur le bureau du procureur le
parquet pourrait initier une enquête
pour déterminer s'il y a eu des lits ou
non
vous avez trois élus qui étaient
présents et la question est de savoir si
on peut considérer du fait de la
présence de ces trois élus qu'on est en
présence d'une injure publique ou non
publique si c'est une injure publique la
peine maximum encourue et de 1 an de
prison et de 45000 euros d'amende si
c'est une injure non publique c'est une
simple contravention et la peine
encourue est une amende maximum de 1500
euros
contacté par notre rédaction le
procureur de la République de Tours
indique qu'aucune procédure n'a
aujourd'hui été ouverte pour cette
affaire